there was a couple of things too in
terms of what emotional parts to have
yeah another way to look at your story
and I think it's a fun exercise to do
with other people's stories and movies
is to look at the forties and think what
proportion of each of these is my story
entertainment education enlightenment or
personal expression take for instance
the Transformers films mostly
entertainment take very little education
maybe a little enlightenment about you
know doing your best to save the world
and probably quite a bit of personal
expression right of the directors desire
to have things go boom but mostly it's
entertainment look at eat Pray Love okay
it's kind of entertaining educational
not much enlightening possibly but
mostly it was about personal expression
it was you know me me me look what I did
and the you know a lot of people really
enjoyed it but it's an example of a
story that's very much about personal
expression and most memoirs are that's
why we write them because we want to
express ourselves but you want to be
sure that in your story you've also got
some entertainment or who's going to
care and if you can enlighten us a bit
raise up our awareness about something
you've maybe you've got a cause or you
want to promote a certain perspective on
life cool and education documentaries of
course but also letting us know
something about something we did not
know now how does that apply to pitching
when you go in to pitch and you're
telling them what your story is you know
this is an action-adventure feature film
that goes along on a journey with a
woman who's looking to save all of the
classical tombs from all the tomb
Raider's that are
taking away all of the treasures and
hurting the study of archeology and the
culture of the people okay but you'd
start off with it's an action-adventure
and female heroine who is trying to do
something good for you know the greater
good or is it well this is a small film
that delves into someone's emotional
journey and takes us from grief to joy
or this is a story that lets say because
I have an educational enlightenment this
is a story about someone who discovers
they are more than they thought they
were and they're able to bring that
message to other people and help them
rise up as well
so yes it's entertaining but it's really
inspirational so just give us a taste of
that and not don't even have to use
those same words but give us a taste of
what your movie is going to be about or
your TV series what we want when we're
sitting on the other side of the table
listening to pitches is we want to be
able to tune in really quickly to what
it is you're offering us when you're
sitting across the table pitching to
someone what we want to hear from you is
what type of story is it that you have
is it features a TV series is it small
or is it big and give us a sense of once
again that sympathy danger salvation you
want us to tune in right away because if
we go you know what we're really not
doing period pieces thank you anyway do
you have something else you've let us
know first before you get into taking
the time to explain your story and then
three minutes in we go oh it's a period
piece oh I'm so sorry we can't do those
so it's like striking that opening chord
and telling us giving us a sense of what
we're going to be hearing
next and a sense of is it going to be
more entertaining or is it enlightening
and inspirational it's it educational
you know think how you would have
pitched 12 years of slave okay it's not
very entertaining but it's educational
about a system that was going on at the
time it's enlightening because of the
hope and the people who did help out and
try to change the system and it's
personal expression in there too so you
start off that pitch with a totally
different tone than you would pitching
the next Transformers film so just let
us know that let let the person you're
pitching to get an idea very very
quickly and and most people who teach
pitching have some really great ideas
there's a lot of people who have written
books but Cathy phone.you Mehta has a
wonderful book about pitching called the
script selling game and it's got
wonderful tools in there
she was an exec at Disney and at
Paramount for many years and worked with
writers and developed stories and she
has some amazingly wonderful workable
tips and tools for pitching I learned a
lot from her
you